an eye-catching pledge on healthcare
from the candidate trailing in this race
for number 10 rishi sunak says he would
charge patients 10 pounds if they
repeatedly fail to turn up for nhs
appointments without notice supporters
say it would be a temporary measure to
help with post-covered pressures we also
have a real problem in this country with
nhs waiting lists
and there's making sure that there is
some kind of penalty there um for those
who are wasting the time at the nhs i
think most people would support that
at a time and we also have to get to
grips the nhs backlog which is also
really important issue facing this
country but as a majority of missed
appointments are in gp surgeries
healthcare analysts say it wouldn't help
with delays and may even backfire
charging people to go to the gp does
nothing for backlogs because all of the
battery logs are in hospital it might
help a little in outpatients but
often those clinics are overbooked
anyway to allow for the fact that people
don't
turn up a big worry is that this creates
an administrative burden particularly
for gps who are already under a huge
workload pressure
liz trust has also been on a policy push
focusing today on education she wants to
widen access to elite universities like
cambridge and oxford saying they should
automatically invite all top grade
students to apply experts say the plan
would be difficult to implement
there's a point in many leadership
contests when the political signal a
policy sends out is more important than
its practicality rishi sunak and liz
trust are pitching hard to tory members
with plans that sound appealing but may
ultimately prove unworkable while the
battle of ideas rages so does the war of
words
the culture secretary has been
criticized for sharing this online post
depicting rishi sunak stabbing boris
johnson in the back
allies of nadine dori say the image is
clearly satirical but liz truss's newest
senior supporter distanced the campaign
from it
certainly not the sort of thing i would
tweet i think we've all got to make sure
that we remember that we are one party
we come back together we work together
we will have different views and the
whole point of a leadership campaign is
that both the candidates and their teams
to outline the differences of opinions
so that the members can then choose who
they think is the best person to lead
our party and to lead our country i
think that's lee's trust i think she's
got a track record of doing that
faced with high-profile endorsements
going to his opponent rishi sunak has
spent the weekend away from the tv
cameras meeting members in the tory
heartlands of southern england with
ballot papers arriving from tomorrow the
coming days will be crucial in deciding
who is in the frame for a win
rob powell sky news in westminster